I think it's just become really
unhealthy Selena Gomez might have
millions of Instagram followers
that's 152 million followers to be exact
but when she stopped by live with Kelly
and Ryan Selena revealed she keeps her
Instagram account on someone else's
phone and only logs in every now and
then check it out it would make me
depressed it would make me feel not good
about myself and there's a look at my
body differently and all kinds of stuff
so I actually don't have it on my phone
I have it on someone else's phone and
when I feel like I want to share
something with my fans or just mess
around that I'd do it then I think
personally for priam people including
myself to to spend all of their time
fixating on all these these comments and
letting this stuff in and it was
affecting me this isn't the first time
Selena has been candid about her
boundaries with social media in April
she opened up on coach's dream at real
podcast I just don't think that it's
healthy to spend too much time on it I
noticed with me I've got kind of
depressed looking at these people who
look beautiful and amazing and it would
just it would get me down a lot so I
just think taking breaks is is really
important but just know that most of it
isn't real and I hate to say that I
don't mean three bro but it's very it's
it's unrealistic in a lot of ways and in
May Selena
upped her intensity on the issue during
a press conference at the Cannes Film
Festival calling social media a danger
to her generation social media has
really been terrible for my generation I
understand that it's amazing to use her
platform but it does scare me when you
see how exposed that these young girls
and young boys are and they're not
really aware of the news or anything
going on Selena did say she's grateful
for the platform but she doesn't quote
do a lot of pointless pictures and it
seems like Selena is even cleaning house
over the weekend
Selena deleted her last remaining
Instagram post referencing her ex Justin
Beiber the 26 year old originally
shared this pic on March 1st 2018 that's
Elina balancing a Polaroid of Justin on
her nose she gave Justin a coy birthday
shout-out in the caption writing quote
March 1st 1994 someone I knew that
happens to be super cool was born boom
the two broke up again shortly after
that you know how the saying goes it
ain't over till you wipe your exes
existence from your Instagram
I love me some Selena and I like that
she's protecting her peace and taking
breaks from social media when she needs
it you do you Selena of course will be
here to keep you up to date on all
things Lena Gomez so make sure to keep
it locked right here on ET until next
time I'm Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]